[Music]
one banana for breakfast ninety calories
let us salad and half a piece of bread
for lunch 300 calories cucumber salad
for dinner eighty calories total 470
calories that was it for the day I spent
the most of my middle-school dealing
with an eating disorder it started from
an article I read about tracking your
eating write down everything you've
eaten and the guilt it creates induces
you to eat less and less and less every
week I lost a pound and this lasted for
about six months it started during my
second year at a boarding school in the
UK I was a child but an extremely self
low self-esteem if you were to meet me
then you would have seen the smallest
girl in the class who couldn't speak
fluent English always hanging out by
herself or was a bear a few friends
accomplishing my goals in diet gave me
confidence in hope that I could become
my ideal self with enough effort living
in a boarding school helped me hide my
diet from everyone the boarding mistress
was taking attendance outside of the
canteen every day to make sure you all
wait so I showed up for the attendance
picked up an apple and went back to my
room I enjoyed being in full control of
my weight I didn't realize I was
entering a bottle my swamp until it was
too late I still remember the fear I
felt when I saw the shower drain thought
with my own hair
that has started to fall off excessively
I didn't know then that the interruption
in my menstrual cycle was a bigger issue
I didn't know how to let go of my diet
and my family's decision was to take
care of me at home instead of using
therapies the mere idea of having to ask
for help made me feel ashamed my thought
my family was horrified though my mother
made every sacrifice and effort she even
flew back to Japan with me so that I can
focus on studies friends anything other
than restricting food we suffered
through without sharing it with anyone
research by Stanford Medical School
shows that with only six month of family
therapies 80% of adolescence anorexia
can be reduced for me it took three
years to recover fully but I was still
lucky adolescence anorexia can lead to
problems in hormone balance bone
development heart disease brain damage
and many other complications 40% of
anorexia or chronic they come back again
and suicide attempts after anorexia can
be up to 20% as I spoke with my Stanford
classmates who have gone through a
similar experience and successfully
recovered through therapies I started to
realize that it doesn't necessarily have
to be this way
and I started wondering what was causing
the shame the shame that I was feeling
jion's I at Stanford Neuroscience
Institute and many other psychologists
define shame as a self-conscious feeling
me feel when we think we have done
something bad or wrong it is similar to
guilt in a way that it's generated when
we don't meet we meet our standards or
norms
whether we care more about how other
people see us and feel ashamed or we
care more about how we feel about
ourselves and feel guilt it's dependent
on cultural context but the root cause
is the same we think we have done
something bad or wrong and for some of
us the mere idea of going to a therapy
and seeking help causes the feeling of
shame seeking help is bad because it's a
show of weakness but would you consider
someone going to a gym is physically
weak we have no problem getting a
trainer and a self assessment and
planning a workout so how is seek
improving our mental health through
therapies so different from improving
our physical health through gym I
witnessed a similar sense of shame at my
first apartment in Tokyo I heard the
strange knocking noise from the floor
above every night from around 10:00 at
first I thought the foul me above us was
using some sort of fitness machine and
made a complaint the noise went away for
a few days but it came back again so one
night I decided to go up and confront
the family myself I was getting really
annoyed as I approached their entrance I
heard this girl's weeping voice leaking
out of their door I still knocked and I
realized that the source of the noise
was their oldest girl hitting on their
living room wall she had developed a
scent a symptom of autism a year into
the top-ranked elementary school in
Japan the family was trying to take care
of the daughter themselves just like my
family
I've had problems too I think you can
ask for help how I wish I could have set
that on this pot instead all I did was I
said that I can acknowledge the
situation and walked off and to this
date it is my biggest regret I wonder
how much pain I could have removed if I
could tell them about my own story and
make them realize that their problems
didn't mean there was something uniquely
wrong with them I wonder how supportive
if I could I could have been if I could
explain to them that seeking help is
nothing to be ashamed of do you remember
your first day at the GSB we were told
that nearly half of the MBA students go
and visit the on-campus therapy during
their two years this surprised me and I
comforted me if I have a problem again I
can ask for help but I know how hard it
is as you are entering that bottle of
swamp to take a step back and seek for
help this is why I want you to be there
open and supportive when your family and
friends are in need of help if you have
an experience in dealing with mental
issues I want you to share your story
with your family and friends sharing can
remove the stigma associated with
disclosure I want you to learn about the
services around you if you're a Stanford
student you can use the on-campus
therapy for free because it's already
covered by the campus health fee we're
all paying
at Stanford it is seen okay or it's even
encouraged to seek for help when we're
having problems but in many other places
this is not the case look back at your
own community with your family your
friends or even your employer open to
the idea of seeking help for mental
issues if not I want you to join me in
becoming the first supporter of seeking
help in your community I want you to
open the people's mind to the fact that
seeking help is nothing special it's
just like going to the gym thank you
[Music]